hey guys I'm Ryan right hi there I'm
Veronica six toes Veronica and I are in
San Diego right now I have to introduce
a film at Comic Con so that's why I'm
not at our set because that is in my
home but today we are in Veronica's
cousins place so thank you Carrie you're
awesome
today we're checking out Jennifer
Lawrence sings shares believe this was
coming in I believe Conan at comic-con
you sang a ballad for Mockingjay it goes
to like number one it's like an
incidental play first of all if I had
done like it would have told that just
hit number one not wasn't me that is my
biggest fear in the entire world
I you do break into song occasionally is
that true does she like to break into
song occasionally yeah yeah she likes to
sing on occasion yeah yeah what do you
like to sing about taking [ __ ] you think
shared yeah which share classic do you
like to say ready
[Music]
[Applause]
I really don't think you're strong
enough oh my god
and things like that in that world of
song wow that's boobs got bigger only I
can comment about her hotness what do
you mean not allowed that's not fair
I love her babe I know you love her I
love her I love her too sometimes when
we do stuff I imagine I'm doing it with
her don't tell me you don't imagine
Jennifer Lawrence sometimes when you're
kissing me all right fine I'll give you
that one
we're doing stuff to my penis you
definitely think you're Jennifer
Lawrence true now she is adorable she's
talented this just earned her a lot more
brownie points oh yeah she's so
relatable what you thought favorite
she's like my favorite because I feel
like she'd just be a buddy of mine yeah
I just like wanna be her BFF anyway yeah
thanks for tuning in if you do do the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects you can check out Veronica 6th
OSes channel it's a lot of fun acoustic
cover songs on there yeah
any kvass on Facebook Instagram Twitter
and vine where if we get enough
followers we can get more product
placement filthy Phil nimeth greetings
from Australia yeah Australia Australia
and fastly holy [ __ ] did well stumbled
across your YouTube channel nice work
right away and the general consensus is
that you're my brother from another
mother report from your exit the guys
here work also seem to think we have the
same mannerisms or even add the same
Chili Peppers shirt that is in your
profile pic what's your ethnic
background if you don't want me asking
or my Filipino half Australian twinsies
well I remember twins look at the
pictures no no when I was 6 years old we
got rid of him well he does
he does kind of like you okay so yeah
you are my doppelganger if you're
anything like me you'll masturbate to
Veronica tonight does it for anything
like me she won't do anything with you
tonight you're disgusting and you're
sweating like crazy lift up your shirt
more I'm trying to get more views lift
up your shirt more I'm trying to get
more views I'm feeling a little bloated
today it's not you know yeah we never do
anything shut up that's not true that's
true twice today